We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. At a very different Kickstarter message written and recorded yesterday. We launched the Kickstarter campaign for season three
我们获得了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是一条昨天撰写并录制的完全不同的 Kickstarter 信息。我们在7月11日发起了
of 99% Invisible on July 11th. And about 24 hours later, we reached the Kickstarter goal. I can't thank you enough. It was one of the most amazing things I've ever been a part of, really stunning. I didn't even have time to release an episode announcing the Kickstarter. But now I have a new goal, a personal goal. 5,000. I want 5,000 Kickstarter backers.
《99%隐形》第三季的 Kickstarter 众筹活动。大约24小时后，我们就达到了 Kickstarter 的目标。我对你们感激不尽。这是我参与过最神奇的事情之一，真的很震撼。我甚至没有时间发布一集节目来宣布 Kickstarter 众筹。但现在我有了新目标，一个个人目标。5000。我想要5000名 Kickstarter 赞助者。
Pledge at any level. The minimum is a dollar. Just a dollar. But any level, there are amazing prizes at all, different kinds of levels. You can go up to $10,000. There's awesome t-shirts and posters and notebooks. It's all stuff that I had someone design because I wanted these items myself. But I'm not even talking about those levels necessarily.
任意金额均可认捐。最低是一美元。只要一美元。无论哪个级别，各个级别都有令人惊艳的奖品。最高可达10,000美元。有很酷的T恤、海报和笔记本。这些东西都是我找人设计的，因为我自己就想要这些物品。但我甚至不一定是在说那些高级别。
I'm just counting backers, people who pledge on Kickstarter for the show at any amount. This is my new, crazily ambitious personal goal of 5,000 backers. And unlike the original Kickstarter goal, this one will likely fail. But if you hit every goal easily, you're not setting them high enough. Fortune favors the bold, my friends. Always remember that. You can go to 99% of visible.org to find the link to donate, or go to Kickstarter and do a search on the show. So, 5,000 backers, that came to me as a number because I want to send a message to the people who control the money in public media that if my little show conceived it, my little radio station of KLW in San Francisco can be this successful and get massive widespread support from people online.
我只是在统计赞助者，也就是在 Kickstarter 上为这个节目进行任意金额认捐的人。这是我疯狂且雄心勃勃的新个人目标，要达到5000名赞助者。和最初的 Kickstarter 目标不同，这个目标很可能会失败。但是，如果你轻而易举地达到了每一个目标，说明你定的目标还不够高。机遇偏爱勇者，我的朋友们。永远记住这一点。你可以访问 99percentinvisible.org 找到捐赠链接，或者去 Kickstarter 搜索这个节目。所以，5000名赞助者，这个数字浮现在我脑海中，是因为我想向那些掌控公共媒体资金的人传达一个信息：如果我的小节目构想出来，我在旧金山的小广播电台 KALW 能取得如此巨大的成功，并获得来自网民的大规模广泛支持。
Then they will all learn to take risks and fund people who make things that are personal and authentic. I'm not talking about Thamine, my nose nose at the man I want to inspire everyone else to be bold and know that if they take the leap and try something great that's maybe a little different like in a regular length video show about architecture will that there are people out there who will help at least 5,000 people that will be something amount. 5,000 people. I want to break Kickstarter. I want to crash the servers.
那么他们都将学会承担风险，去资助那些制作个人化且真实内容的人。我不是在说……我是想激励其他人要勇敢，让他们知道如果他们勇敢一跃，尝试一些伟大的、可能有点不同的东西——比如一档常规长度的建筑视频节目——会有这样的人伸出援手，至少有5000人，那将是一个不小的数目。5000人。我想打破 Kickstarter。我想让服务器崩溃。
I want one of those crazy Kickstarter success stories to be about a little public radio show instead of a high tech gadget. Wouldn't that be cool? 99%Avisible.org or just do a search on Kickstarter. And be one of the 5,000. Thanks. Here's the show. This is 99% Invisible.
我想让那些疯狂的 Kickstarter 成功故事的主角是一个小型公共广播节目，而不是高科技小工具。那不是很酷吗？99percentinvisible.org，或者直接在 Kickstarter 上搜索。成为那5000人之一。谢谢。节目开始。这里是《99%隐形》。
I'm Roman Mars. The hotel on the very prominent corner of Tué in Kilburn Avenue in Lincolnwood, Illinois used to be the town's most famous building. The first high at Hotel and all of Chicago land, premier accommodations, top notch restaurant. It was swank. Roberta Flack stayed there. Barry Manelow stayed there.
我是罗曼·马尔斯。位于伊利诺伊州林肯伍德图厄街和基尔博恩大道交汇显眼处的这家酒店曾是该镇最著名的建筑。它是整个芝加哥地区第一家凯悦酒店，提供一流的住宿和顶级的餐厅。它曾是那么时髦。罗伯塔·弗莱克曾下榻于此。巴里·曼尼洛曾下榻于此。
Perry Como. Michael Jordan stayed there on his first night in Chicago. And every 13-year-old boy in the area had his permits for there. and every 13-year-old boy in the area had his permits for there. The hotel was built in 1960, and it looks it. So if you're wondering how much potentially an agronistic lounge music I'm going to cram into this episode, oh, it's going to be a lot. Then slowly over time, it became Lincoln Woods' most infamous building.
佩里·科莫。迈克尔·乔丹在芝加哥的第一晚就住在那里。当地的每一个13岁男孩都在那里办过……当地的每一个13岁男孩都在那里办过。这家酒店建于1960年，看起来确实如此。所以如果你想知道我打算把多少潜在的、带有侵略性的酒廊音乐塞进这一集里，哦，那可多了去了。然后慢慢地，随着时间推移，它成了林肯伍德最声名狼藉的建筑。
It changed hands, got seedy, and run down. It was the home of the Midwest fetish fair and marketplace convention. There were drug-fueled sex parties attended by shady Chicago politicians later convicted of things like extortion. And of course, there was the convicted mobster Alan Dorfman, who was gunned down in the parking lot. But that's not why everyone in the area knows the building. If you know nothing of its history, it's still pretty hard to miss.
它几经易手，变得破败不堪。这里曾是中西部恋物癖展销会和集市大会的举办地。这里充斥着由声名狼藉的芝加哥政客参加的、毒品泛滥的性派对，这些政客后来因敲诈勒索等罪名被定罪。当然，还有被定罪的黑帮分子艾伦·多夫曼，他在停车场被枪杀。但这不是当地每个人都知道这座建筑的原因。如果你对它的历史一无所知，它依然很难被忽视。
Because it's purple. Really, really purple. Growing up nearby, I always thought it was really, really ugly. Lots of people did. To be fair, lots of people didn't, but everyone had an opinion about it. McGuin Maxi, that's what I'm talking to now, by the way.
因为它实在是紫色的。真的非常非常紫。在附近长大的我，一直觉得它真的非常非常丑。很多人都这么觉得。公平地说，也有很多人不这么觉得，但每个人对它都有看法。格温·马克西，顺便说一下，我现在就是在跟她说话。
Noted S.A.S.D. in public video host, and she even created a sitcom once. She has a secret about the purple hotel. My father designed it. My name is John Maxx. I'm a retired architect and former professor at UIC. I designed a lot of... Just a building. Don't enter up. You I see I designed a lot of just the building
她是著名的 S.A.S.D. 公共视频主持人，她甚至还创作过一部情景喜剧。她对这座紫色酒店有一个秘密。我父亲设计了它。我叫约翰·马克西。我是一名退休建筑师，也是伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校的前教授。我设计了许多……只是一栋建筑。别打断我。你……伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校，我设计了许多……只是一栋建筑。
Nothing to rob Okay, I designed a lot of apartment buildings in Chicago We're here to talk about the purple hotel. I need to say I designed my name is John Maxx. I'm an architect I designed the purple hotel My name is John Maxxx. I'm an architect. I designed this purple hotel. My name is John Maxx, I'm an architect, and I was the designer of the purple hotel. Finally, now you have to understand that when I say the building is purple, I don't mean the kind of purple of say an iris or a plum.
没什么好吹嘘的。好吧，我在芝加哥设计了许多公寓楼。我们是来谈论紫色酒店的。我需要说我设计了……我叫约翰·马克西。我是一名建筑师。我设计了紫色酒店。我叫约翰·马克西。我是一名建筑师。我设计了这座紫色酒店。我叫约翰·马克西，我是一名建筑师，我是紫色酒店的设计师。好吧，现在你必须明白，当我大声说这座建筑是紫色的时候，我指的不是那种鸢尾花或李子般的紫色。
It's purple as in lavender. Lavender purple glazed brick all over pretty much the entire thing. Which Needless to say makes it stand out. Depending on how you look at it, like a prize jewel or a sore thumb. You know, that's one of the few buildings that if you see it once, you know, it's, you've seen it forever. You can't, you know, get the image of it all you want. It is so purple that after it changed hands, the new owners renamed it the purple hotel.
它是薰衣草般的紫。几乎整个建筑都贴满了薰衣草紫色的釉面砖。这不用说，让它非常显眼。取决于你如何看待它，它要么像一颗珍贵的宝石，要么像一根刺眼的芒刺。你知道，那是少数几栋只要你看过一次，就知道、就会永远记住的建筑。无论你怎么想，你都无法从脑海中抹去它的形象。它是如此的紫色，以至于在它易手后，新业主将其重新命名为“紫色酒店”。
WB Easy Architecture Critic, Lee Bay. I think that it's worth looking at absent the brick. The brick I like, but I wish you could sort of put on glasses, I could filter it out so you don't see the brick at least in one trip and really see how the building holds this up together structurally. I mean mean I think it's really good. The way the John was able to put those supports on the outside of the hotel to give larger floor plates in the middle, which is what you want. You want big functional spaces instead of a set of a hotel. And then again the little nooks of green
WBEZ 建筑评论员李·贝伊。我认为剥离砖块来审视它是很有价值的。我喜欢这些砖块，但我希望你能戴上某种眼镜，我可以把它过滤掉，这样你至少在第一眼时看不到砖块，从而真正看清这座建筑在结构上是如何支撑起这一切的。我的意思是，我认为它真的很棒。约翰能够将那些支撑结构放在酒店外部，从而在中间创造出更大的楼板面积，这正是你想要的。你想要的是宏大实用的空间，而不是一堆……而不是一堆酒店房间。然后还有那些绿色的角落
space and the way that the sort of the building is kind of fit together, the complex fits together. I mean really there's really a lot of good things going on there. You know, I say, come for the purple, but stay for the architecture. The thing that everybody notices first, including architects, would be the color. I mean, I think that if anybody is saying that it's not the color that they're lying, because you can't really look at the building without noticing that it's purple. So it's the only purple building around, but then, you know, after that initial wave of
空间，以及建筑拼合在一起的方式，整个综合体拼合在一起的方式。我的意思是，真的有很多很棒的设计。你知道，我说过，为紫色而来，为建筑而留。每个人首先注意到的东西，包括建筑师在内，就是颜色。我的意思是，如果有人说不是颜色吸引了他们，那他们在撒谎，因为你无法在不注意到它是紫色A的情况下看着这座建筑。所以它是周围唯一的紫色建筑，但是呢，在你经历那一波最初的
color hits you, you notice really what a great modernist structure it has and how the structure is expressed on the outside, which is also not something you see every day anymore. And I think it's a wonderful building. That was Jackie Koo, founding principal of the architectural firm Koo & Associates. We'll get back to her in a minute. But first, the story of why and how the building got to be so purple. My dad, John Maxi. It was commissioned by the Pritzkers, the very rich family in Chicago, and it was the first Hyatt Hotel in the Midwest. It was called Hyatt Hoss. Nothing to do with the purple.
色彩冲击之后，你会真正注意到它是一座多么棒的现代主义结构，以及这种结构是如何在外部表现出来的，这也是你现在不常看到的。我认为这是一座绝妙的建筑。那是杰基·库，建筑事务所库与合伙公司的创始合伙人。我们一会儿再谈她。但首先，讲讲这座建筑为什么以及如何变得如此紫色的故事。我父亲，约翰·马克西。它是由普利兹克家族委托建造的，普利兹克家族是芝加哥非常富有的家族，这是中西部第一家凯悦酒店。它当时叫凯悦豪斯。跟紫色毫无关系。
By the way, the purple came because one of the Pritzkers, A.N., the big man among the Pritzkers in the family, as we, what color-glace style I want to use. And I wanted to use gray, and he said said that's dull. I like something brighter. So I made a mistake of showing him the samples of books, having on it some 35, 40 colored samples and sure enough, you picked a purple and you don't argue with Ian Fritzkerr. My father tells me this story, but I suspect differently. He's always gravitated toward bold color choices. Our current argument is over bright orange balconies on a building that we always pass,
顺便说一句，紫色的出现是因为普利兹克家族的一位成员，A.N.，普利兹克家族的大人物，当时我们……问我想用什么颜色的釉面砖。我想用灰色，他说这太沉闷了。我喜欢更亮一点的。于是我犯了个错误，给他看了一本样品册，里面大约有35、40种颜色样品，果不其然，他挑了一种紫色，你可不能跟安·普利兹克争论。我父亲跟我讲了这个故事，但我的看法有所不同。他一直都倾向于大胆的色彩选择。我们目前争论的焦点是一栋我们经常路过的建筑上的亮橙色阳台，
he loves them, and I hate them. When I was growing up, his favorite color was blue. A color that, to me, is suspiciously close to purple. In fact, every house we ever lived in, brick bungalow, summer house in the woods, suburban barn-shaped house with mustard-colored siding, all had bright blue front doors. That my father painted. My elementary school bus driver used to call me blue door.
他很喜欢，而我讨厌。我长大的时候，他最喜欢的颜色是蓝色。在我看来，这种颜色跟紫色有着可疑的相似之处。事实上，我们住过的每一所房子——砖砌平房、树林里的避暑别墅、有着芥末色护墙板的郊区谷仓式房屋——都有亮蓝色的前门。都是我父亲漆的。我小学的校车司机以前叫我“蓝门”。
Upon interrogation, my father coughed up his strange Hungarian logic. In the Near East where ultimately I come from, the blue color on the doors, blue and green, is to keep the evil spirit away. So that's a reason I always expected the entrance door of our houses blue to keep the evil spirit away. And it did. Do you think it worked for the hotel? So you don't think the purple kept away the evil eye from the hotel? Not really, because there was a murder in the hotel.
经过盘问，我父亲吐露了他那奇怪的匈牙利逻辑。在近东，也就是我最终的故乡，门上的蓝色——蓝色和绿色——是为了驱除恶灵。所以这就是为什么我一直期望我们家的入户门是蓝色的，用来驱除恶灵。而且确实管用。你觉得它对酒店也管用了吗？所以你认为紫色并没有为酒店挡住邪眼吗？其实并没有，因为酒店里发生过谋杀案。
Actually, there were two, but I digress. The beauty of that building is the exposed concrete frame. How the columns are pulled out of the structure, showing this... It's like a human being whose skeleton will be on the exterior partially. That would be weird, right? Well, that's the way that building is. The columns are pulled out. The slabs are slightly pulled out.
事实上，发生过两起，不过我扯远了。那栋建筑的美妙之处在于外露的混凝土框架。柱子是如何从结构中抽离出来的，展现出这个……这就像一个人，他的骨骼部分暴露在外部。那会很奇怪，对吧？嗯，这座建筑就是这样的。柱子被抽出来了。楼板也被稍微抽出来了。
It's a building which reveals its structure. And that is architecturally the interesting thing about it. The purple is totally irrelevant. It could be green, okay? It would be the same good or bad building. So as an architect, I have to ask you, this is a perfect example of what the difference between what the public sees and what the architect sees. Oh, absolutely.
这是一栋展现其结构的建筑。从建筑学上讲，这才是它有趣的地方。紫色完全无关紧要。它可以是绿色的，好吧？它作为一栋建筑的好坏程度是一样的。所以作为一名建筑师，我不得不问你，这是一个完美的例子，展示了公众看到的和建筑师看到的之间有什么区别。哦，绝对是这样。
Because the public sees Purple Brick, the architect is sitting here saying the purple is so unimportant in the scheme of the building. It means nothing. It's just such a tiny thing. But to the public, that's all it is. That's right, because the public is ignorant. That truly ignorant. Well, you can't really argue with them there, but in our defense, and I count myself as
因为公众看到的是紫砖，而建筑师坐在这里说，紫色在整个建筑方案中是多么不重要。它毫无意义。这只是一件微不足道的小事。但对公众来说，这就是全部。没错，因为公众是无知的。真的是无知。好吧，在这点上你确实没法反驳他们，但为了我们辩护——我也把自己算作
one of the public in the scenario, it's really, really purple. And despite how far the purple hotel fell from its original glory, the dilapidation, the murder, the drug-fueled sex parties, and a demolition order. It was not torn down. Time passed, the economy fell to pieces. Mid-century architecture slowly came back into vogue. Mad Men was on TV. The Purple Brick was kind of retro-cool.
这个场景中的公众之一——它是真的非常非常紫。尽管紫色酒店从昔日的辉煌中跌落，经历了破败、谋杀、毒品泛滥的性派对以及拆迁令。它并没有被拆除。时光流逝，经济崩溃。中世纪现代主义建筑慢慢重回时尚。电视上正播着《广告狂人》。紫砖变得有点复古酷炫。
A light, however dim, was starting to shine on the building of its future. Then, the Purple Hotel was nominated for landmark status, a place on the historic registry. There was talk of finding a buyer, talk of renovation, and then while I was searching and interviewing for this very story, the purple hotel went up for auction. There was a lot of pomp and circumstance in the beginning of, you know, the auctioneer, yelling and saying, are you ready and, you know, in the booming voice and then really there was only one bitter, so. And that bitter was Jake Weiss of Weiss Properties in Skokie, which happens to be right next
一束光，尽管微弱，开始照亮这座建筑的未来。然后，紫色酒店被提名具有地标地位，列入历史名册。有人在谈论寻找买家，谈论翻新，就在我为这个故事进行搜索和采访时，紫色酒店被拿出来拍卖了。拍卖开始时有很多盛大的仪式，你知道的，拍卖师大喊大叫，说你们准备好了吗，用那种轰鸣的声音，然后实际上只有一个竞标者。而那个竞标者是来自斯托基的 Weiss Properties 公司的杰克·维斯，斯托基恰好就在
to Lincolnwood. He bought the purple hotel, and while Weiss is a shrewd businessman with a keen eye and good instincts, this particular purchase was also a labor of love. When you have something that really is just not realizing its value and its potential that has such a prime piece of property, it bothers you, you know, it's part of your neighborhood, it's part of your community, and it's something that you really want to see be an asset to the community instead of a blight. Here comes the love part. Separately from that, when my, and more importantly, I think,
林肯伍德隔壁。他买下了紫色酒店，虽然维斯是一位精明的商人，有着敏锐的眼光和良好的直觉，但这次特殊的收购也是一项出于热爱的工作。当你拥有某种没有真正实现其价值和潜力、却又占据如此优越地段的资产时，这会困扰你，你知道的，这是你社区的一部分，是你家园的一部分，是你真正希望看到它成为社区的资产而不是疮痍的东西。真情流露的部分来了。除此之外，当我的……更重要的是，我认为，
we almost lived at the purple hotel for a period of time, when my grandfather had passed away and my father was saying the traditional kathish. That's the Jewish prayer for the dead. When my grandfather had passed away in my father was saying the traditional kathish. That's the Jewish prayer for the dead. There was no synagogue anywhere in close proximity to where he lived at the time. And because we're Orthodox and we're going to drive on a Sabbath, that was a little bit prohibitive to say the kathish. There's a very convenient shoulder right down the block.
我们有一段时间几乎住在紫色酒店里，那时我的祖父去世了，我父亲正在念传统的悼词。那是犹太人悼念死者的祈祷文。当我祖父去世，我父亲在念传统的犹太悼词时。他当时住的地方附近没有任何犹太会堂。因为我们是正统派犹太人，安息日不能开车，这在念悼词方面带来了一些限制。街区尽头有一个非常方便的街肩。
Also known as a synagogue. The congregation in Houtamosa. So on every single shop is for a year, we would move into the purple hotel to accommodate my father's responsibility to say the cahdish for his father. So we lived there for about a year every single weekend. And you know, me and my sister, the hotel was our playground. And the architect Weiss has chosen to redesign the purple hotel and bring it back to its original
也被称为犹太会堂。Houtamosa 会众。因此，整整一年里，每个店铺开放日，我们都会搬进紫色酒店，以满足我父亲为他父亲念悼词的责任。所以我们几乎每个周末都在那里住大约一年。你知道的，我和我姐姐，这座酒店就是我们的游乐场。而维斯选择来重新设计紫色酒店并使其恢复昔日
luster is Jackie Koo of Jackie Koo and Associates. Also, a former student of my father, the original architect, John Maxi. One of the things that we're looking into is more of a historic restoration of the building. And it would be wonderful. And especially since we have some of the building. And it would be wonderful and especially since we have some of the old drawings, the original drawings from the 60s, 1961, when it
光彩的建筑师是杰基·库建筑事务所的杰基·库。她也是我父亲（最初的建筑师约翰·马克西）的前学生。我们正在研究的事情之一是对建筑进行更多历史性的修复。这将是一件美妙的事。特别是我们还保留了一些建筑的……这将是一件美妙的事，特别是我们还保留了一些旧图纸，即60年代最初的图纸，也就是1961年它
was constructed. And there are a lot of pieces that are still left in the building such as this wonderful monumental Tarazo stair with this wood wall behind it. I mean you can really see it as this kind of late 50s, early 60s kind of madmen, era, pan-am sort of hotel that really could be very current in today's hospitality environment. The culture today, especially in the hospitality market, for some reason purple is a predominant color, not necessarily in the color of the brick, but in older marketing. I mean, you'll look at the neon lights and the color of the key fob cards
被建造起来。大楼里还留存着许多部件，比如这个宏伟的水磨石楼梯，后面是木质墙壁。我的意思是，你真的可以把它看作是一种50年代末、60年代初那种《广告狂人》时代、泛美航空式的酒店，在今天的酒店业环境中它完全可以非常时尚。如今的文化，特别是在酒店市场，不知为何紫色成了主色调，不一定体现在砖块的颜色上，而是在早期的营销中。我的意思是，你会看到霓虹灯、房卡吊牌的颜色
and the brochures that get printed for some reason purple is popping, and I'm not quite sure why. Have any of your buildings had this kind of history, this kind of life cycle that you know of? No, none of them. The same way that a person they go through life and you might go through different cycles yourself and everybody goes through different rebellious times and ups and downs,
以及印刷出来的宣传册，不知为何紫色总是很显眼，我不太确定原因。你们的建筑里有没有过这种历史，这种你们所了解的生命周期？没有，一个也没有。就像一个人，他们经历了人生，你可能自己也经历过不同的周期，每个人都会经历不同的叛逆期以及高潮与低谷，
I think the same holds true for a property like this that really was a character of itself. The building was really a product of the environment around it at any given time. And, you know, to a certain extent, the fact that the building did change with the decades and the environment around it, it really is the building's character. And longs true that this character, this building, this structure of nine lives sits empty at the moment, surrounded by bored traffic and an empty parking lot, it may just be crouching, gathering its muster, ready to spring back to life, arresting that traffic, and strutting like a proud peacock. A purple one. 99% invisible was produced this week by Gwen Maxine, host of ReCend,
我认为对于这样一个本身就很有个性的物业来说也是如此。在任何特定时期，这座建筑确实都是它周围环境的产物。而且，你知道，在某种程度上，这座建筑随着几十年及其周边环境的变化而改变，这确实就是这座建筑的性格。而真实的情况是，这个性格、这座建筑、这个拥有九条命的结构目前却空置着，四周环绕着无聊的车流和空荡荡的停车场，它可能只是在蹲伏，积蓄力量，准备重新焕发生机，吸引住那些车流，像一只骄傲的孔雀一样昂首阔步。一只紫色的孔雀。《99%隐形》本周由ReCend的主持人Gwen Maxine制作，
from the Third Coast International Audio Festival, with a little help from me Roman Mars. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Support for 99% of visible is provided in part by the Facebook design team who believes that design can bring positive change to the world and is at them at facebook.com slash design. Support is also provided by Tiny Letter. Email for people with something to say. My boy Maslow always has something to say.
来自第三海岸国际音频节，并在我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）的一点帮助下完成。这是旧金山当地公共广播KALW-91.7以及美国建筑师协会旧金山分会的一个项目。《99%隐形》的部分资金支持来自Facebook设计团队，他们坚信设计能给世界带来积极的改变，网址是facebook.com/design。资金支持还来自Tiny Letter。为有话要说的人准备的电子邮件。我的好兄弟马斯洛总是有话要说。
What do you have to say Maslow? There's way to say things on my name. What does that mean? It means not today. It's not me. It's not me. It's not me. It's not me. TinyWetter.com, the simplest way to write an email newsletter from the people behind MailChimp. This program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public online at PRX.org.
你要说什么，马斯洛？有很多方式可以表达我的名字。那是什么意思？意思是今天不行。不是我。不是我。不是我。不是我。TinyWetter.com，由MailChimp幕后团队打造的最简单的电子邮件通讯撰写方式。本程序由PRX分发，PRX是一个公共广播交流平台，致力于通过PRX.org让公共广播在网络上更加普及。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. But this week, you're going to want to go to 99%invisible.org and look at pictures of the purple hotel and become one of the 5,000. Come on, don't think. Just go. Go to Kickstarter. Let's make this happen. Right now, I'm optimistic. I might feel differently in the except the same. But let's do it happen right now. I'm optimistic all might feel differently except this But let's do it. Come on. Thanks
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上的名字是Roman Mars。但本周，你会想去 99%invisible.org 看看这家紫色酒店的照片，并成为那5,000人之一。来吧，别多想。去吧。去Kickstarter。让我们把这事办成。现在，我很乐观。除了同样的感觉外，我可能会有不同的感受。但让我们现在就把它实现。我很乐观，虽然除了这个之外我可能会有别的感受，但让我们做吧。来吧。谢谢
Does the name mad men mean anything to you mad man Mad men no Nothing no association with that word. Repeat it again. Mad men. Mad men. Mad men. Mad men.
"mad men"这个名字对你有什么意义吗？疯子 疯子 疯子 没有。没有。对这个词没有任何联想。再重复一遍。广告狂人。广告狂人。广告狂人。广告狂人。
Easy. Yes. But it's also the name of a television show? No, no, I haven't watched it. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
容易。是的。但这也是一部电视节目名字？不，不，我没看过。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。